لماذا استحضار هذه السيده في لص روايه اخي
احمد كان الاولاني الفكره
هي كاتبه امريكيه من اصول بافاريا من
المانيا
[موسيقى]
انتقلت الى لندن في فتره معينه بدايه
القرن ال 20 ثم سنه 1905 انتقلت الى باريس
وعاشت في باريس
ومن اوائل من اشتراه وقتلوا اللوحات من
بيكاسو
[موسيقى]
مصادفه كنت في الدار البيضاء لدى باعت
الكتب المستعمله اشتريت سيره ذاتيه
السيره الذاتيه لاليس تو كلاس اليسا
في فرنسا كانت لها سابق معرفه في
كاليفورنيا
وعاشت السيده
في بيت واحد كانت هذه السيده تخدمها في كل
شيء
تعتبر من مرتكزات العصر الذهبي لباريس كان
بيتها يعني مازارا
حتى ان الامريكيين كانوا يقولون من يريد
ان يذهب الى باريس لابد من ان يتردد او
يزور معلمتين
كلهم المدنيين والعسكريين كان فمثلا
ارنستينين
الاخر وهو شاب في بدايته
في باريس
الذهبي
صحيح ههه
ولها كل اسبوع يوم السبت منتدى او نادي
ادبي فني يحضره
وشعراء وفنانين وزراء الى اخر على كل حال
اشتريت هذه الكتاب مصادفه وجدت فيه فقره
زارت سنه 1912
مدينه طنجه
هي وصديقتها اريستون كلاس وتشيروا الى ان
الزياره اكتشفت شابا طنجاويه من مدينه
طنجه اسمه محمد تقول هذا اسمه محمد همم
ساعدنا كثيرا وعرفنا بالمدينه وهذا الشاب
كان قد كبر في قصر السلطان مولاي حفيظ وهو
الذي اخبرنا بان السلطان يحفظ سيتنحى عن
العرش بل ذكر لنا حتى المبلغ الذي سيتسلمه
السلطان
حقائق
تكلفه هذه